[Music]
today we're building a moving table
trying to play with both ping pong balls
and more let's get into it okay for all
the night shots let's do it level one
two
level three
four five
I was gonna pull up my shorts this can
be the level six
level seven did to my leg
[Applause]
s
fixed rollers okay maybe we don't tell
you what the next challenge is you just
have to guess we're building these
things are they skateboards
okay that one's quickly so if me and
Emma left the table or not to you okay
you fit them oh this is exciting we have
no idea if this works
oh my god it works so now you guys may
be guessing what the next challenge
might be I'm wondering how this will
affect the gameplay because it's 20
centimeters higher than normal that's
true level one
it's really hard to focus
[Music]
there's a lot of ways here
you don't have a racket
internet
but I I didn't get it in time
you guys keep your sides and I spin the
table
[Applause]
[Music]
no you didn't
come on guys
good save
make sure to watch until the end for an
even crazier two versus two moving table
match welcome to the pongfinity cooking
show today we're going to show you how
to boil a perfect ping pong ball we also
have a few different kind of balls
here's the pawn finity ball best ball in
the world let's see how it survives fun
fact if you step on a ball it pops back
into the original shape this one's
already turning it hasn't even been a
minute I'm giving the full submersion
treatment for this the one minute ball
and the five minute ball it's a bit
flatter let's go and play with them
[Music]
super annoying you can't control it I
wonder if you can like tactic
[Music]
yeah you just serve on the side of the
flat side this is an even worse one
that's good
whoa oh nice save almost this isn't
quite random enough for it to be fun I
wouldn't recommend it
on to the next challenge
[Applause]
curve around the tapes
[Music]
that's level one let's see how far Otto
can make it at least level 58 level two
[Music]
you can do it
yeah
level three Mika stop fooling around
time for level four
level four level five
[Music]
[Applause]
level six
[Music]
now it's getting harder yeah level seven
tape level eight
[Music]
oh
me and Otto against Emil and Lassie and
me and Lassie are going to be the table
movers well we are the finished
champions in doubles
but but you're the Finnish Championship
normal doubles yeah we are the Tempest
in every doubles whatever doubles we try
yeah but if if we beat you with Lassie
then we're officially the uh the best in
Finland yes we'll be foster if you move
I think
yes
but to give me around the net spot there
you have it
yeah come on evil
done it
that was a good one
yeah
no no
thanks guys
is that okay
we're gonna win this yeah yeah
I'll put a high one
foreign
challenge like you should definitely try
this out if you if you wanna if you want
to make this setup this is how you do it
yeah do a good workout also yeah a
really good workout yeah last year's
sweating too and guys only 18 of our
viewers are subscribed so make sure to
subscribe if this video put a smile on
your face